del altar al frente de batalla esta
pareja decidió casarse antes de que
andrey dejara su ciudad bataisk para
unirse a las tropas de Moscú
un Cambio de planes por el anuncio del
presidente Vladimir Putin de convocar
300.000 reservistas adicionales Para
apoyar las operaciones militares en
Ucrania no lo estábamos planeando pero
hemos decidido registrar nuestros
matrimonios tras la ceremonia Andrés se
unió a varios de sus compañeros
canciones que recordaban a la Segunda
Guerra Mundial y las lágrimas de muchos
de sus familiares marcaron el ingreso al
bus que los llevaría al frente una
despedida llena de sentimientos como
Andrea y miles se preparan para unirse
al ejército ruso chequeos médicos y
papeleos son los últimos detalles antes
de la partida
recibió el aviso de reclutamiento ayer
un hombre bien y me lo dio mamá no
estaba feliz pero qué podemos hacer
Tenemos que defender nuestro país
el proceso de movilización de vistas ha
generado fuertes críticas y protestas en
Rusia unas que llevaron al kremlin
asegurar el lunes que hubo errores
durante el proceso de convocatoria
estos casos de discrepancia con Los
criterios necesarios se están arreglando
Esperamos que la velocidad de fijación
aumente que todos los errores sean
corregidos
sin embargo el anuncio de vivo en
múltiples manifestaciones en Rusia en
las que más de 2000 personas fueron
detenidas al mismo tiempo muchos han
intentado huir del país agotando Los
tiquetes de avión y generando largas
filas en los cruces fronterizos